on Research Hub you can earn research
coin through uh comments
through having your content
upvoted having people tip you that they
when they think your work is good so it
helps kind of level the playing field
for
people uh in getting financially
compensated for their expertise because
yes reputation is important in Academia
but also like if you go to the grocery
store and you say hey this is my
reputation can I have some
food they're going to say yeah cool um
we only accept currency like fiat
currency for the physical Goods that we
have so hello and welcome to the Shiki
science show where in this video I spoke
with Cole Deli a fellow YouTuber of
investigate explore discover with a
background in
Immunology however here we discuss
Cole's involvement with research hub a
platform that is changing the way in
which scientific research can be
accessed and funded as you will shortly
find out so hi Cole good to see you and
welcome to the Shiki Science Show hi
Elanor thank you for having me on no
problem well I wanted to reach out to
you because uh I noticed your recent uh
um interest in research Hub and how
you've been using it to do your own
independent research which is kind of
interesting because I feel like one of
the first conversations we had about a
year ago now was all about research
um and I think if anything I maybe was
the first person to tell you about it
and so yeah my initial understanding of
research H was it was kind of like an
alternative platform to upload research
papers and discuss it kind of like a
Twitter for research papers but since
then I feel like there's all sorts of
new features that have been added so I
guess firstly yeah would you be able to
elaborate a bit more about how what
research research Hub is to you sure so
I mean research Hub as it is is a
platform with a goal to accelerate the
pace of science uh it does this through
peerreview uh scientific
discourse there is now a reference
manager to help people organize their
research in writing papers uh and
recently they've started doing uh
funding of projects through submission
of pre-registrations which are basically
like study plans study outlines study
plans for research projects
yeah I mean research Hub super exciting
uh been it's grown a lot uh since we
first talked about it and grown
exponentially I think over the last
month wow nice so very exciting to talk
with people specifically about science
uh and see new
developments nice because when we fast
mat I think um you said that your
background was in immunology and so was
that how you initially were interacting
with papers because I know now as we'll
go on to you're doing research around
plant biology and I was just curious to
find out um how using research Hub has
maybe influence the sort of topics that
you've been reading about yeah so my
background is in Immunology uh the
highest degree I hold is a
master's at that point I decided time to
get out of Academia and move on uh I've
always had an interest in plant biology
that just wasn't what I did in school so
the project that I'm work or that got
funded through research Hub is working
on really a personal as or it's it's
really just interesting to me personally
and I'm doing this in conjunction with
my fiance so we're both working on
how looking at or we're both looking at
how music can influence plant growth so
uh I'll just dive a bit into the project
what it is is it's a hydroponic growth
or a hydroponic setup for growing
lettuce in uh basically a soundproof box
which you can see behind me nice that's
where it's being
performed uh There are 16 different
variables that we're looking to control
so it's kind of a broad study but this
area of research isn't very well
developed like it's it's been out there
it's been out there I
think
really notably I think since the 70s but
there's research on it going back to I
think as early as the
50s so there just hasn't been a lot
studied on this and there's been
basically no information on how music
affects hydroponic systems which I think
are a better growing method if you're
looking at uh commercial growth because
plants typically grow faster uh they can
be grown in less area they
use I don't know about the nutrients but
it's just easier and faster to
grow I see so how are you uh using
research Hub then to sort of do this
research project with research Hub
uh I first submitted a proposal in the
form of a
pre-registration uh on the platform I
interacted with many people from the
community and got tons of constructive
feedback on as to how to best uh
formulate the questions and tweak the
setup once I submitted uh another
document with those
revisions the community came together to
help fund this the whole project I think
my costs were including all the
materials and my time about
$1,600 and so This research project got
funded in under two hours from the
community wow okay cool and so it got
funded for $2,000 at which point I
converted well and it got uh funded
through research coin which is research
hubs native crypto
token so I took that research coin I
immediately converted it into ethereum
which then I converted into US dollars
and moved to my bank to compensate or to
reimburse because I had already bought
the materials uh me for the materials I
see yeah P we should probably expand
elizabe on the research coins so how is
the funding like achieved on the
platform so it's coming so the funding
that eventually went to the research
coin that you received where did that
like originally come from uh it was from
uh multiple different community members
so it's really a proof of concept that
research Hub can be a platform for
helping fund people's science so people
can come together
for funding things that they think are
interesting to accelerate the pace of
science this because if I were to look
at traditional funding methods I don't
think I would be able to have funded
this project because this is in a new
field of study I mean I have done a
bunch of research looking up how to do
the background on it and I'm in the
process of writing a review for
that but it
gives scientists I think really the
opportunity to look into interesting
questions that they might have always
had in the back of their mind or just
recently came up with
and provides Community Support to
actually do that I see and so um at the
moment was this the first uh project
that actually received funding
successfully or has there been multiple
attempts to do this this is the first
project that research Hub has
successfully funded I see because I was
just wondering I mean um do you think
there are certain projects that are more
likely to get funded than others or how
is like is it purely based on people
being interested in the ass project that
therefore it will receive funding or is
there any sort of additional regulation
over how people might choose to fund
projects at this point in time I think
it is number one how feasible your
experiment is so with the
pre-registration including all of the
relevant details to how you're going to
do it what variables you're looking at
how you're going to control it if you
know what the background is so that way
you can make or you can postulate
informed
questions uh in terms of
topics right now I don't think there is
any limit on the types of research that
will be that could be funded
uh it's really what's feasible and what
people think are
interesting I see and so uh do you have
any idea like uh the sort of
demographics of people that are using
the platform at the moment or any idea I
mean the people who have donated
research coin that you could then use to
fund the project are they then able to
guess like track and see your progress
over time yes so I've been providing uh
updates on this experience so every two
days I take measurements of the plants
and upload them to research hub for
people to look at so the experiment
because it's being done in real time
there's also the opportunity to look at
how it's progressing
uh how is it progressing I'm G kind of
curious myself it's interesting I mean
right now I'm starting with uh a no
sound control un I found yesterday when
doing the maintenance on it that the
pump pump had been
unplugged so I think that kind of
unfortunately invalidates this as a
proper control because water needs
aeration or yeah the water that plants
take up needs
irration to help grow effectively and if
there was a period of time where the
water was not being air rated that can
stunt plant growth so for having that
period of time I don't think that this
is I don't think it's a suitable control
and if you have a control you need it ex
as exact as the other uh treatments are
going to be I could modify it to do that
in all of them but it also feels
disingenuous to do that and wouldn't
properly capture what the experiment is
supposed to be so I can as with all
science there are always hiccups in
experiments I can relate uh
and this I think is just one of them uh
it happens you just take it you learn
from it and move forward but the plants
themselves are growing actually really
fantastically uh what is it if I look
through some of my
notes pretty much every two days since
they've the uh lettuce has been pruned
the length and width the length has
length of the radicals has been going up
by about a centimeter every two
days and the width has been I would say
about half a
centimeter nice so really interesting
it's only 14 days in uh I think it will
still provide interesting Insight on
just how fast we can expect lettuce to
grow because I know many people grow
lettuce hydroponically in these Arrow
Gardens just out of Interest they grow
herbs uh you can grow tomatoes like
whatever I've got a bunch of them in my
house
already uh but I don't think that it's
been documented in this
way I see no I mean because yeah what is
the main uh like depending on your
findings how are you are hoping maybe in
the future to apply some of this
research that you're doing uh so if
there is a specific music treatment that
increases the growth of lettuce over the
control I think that provides
justification for Farmers that are doing
indoor vertical hydroponic gardening to
also apply the sound treatment to
increase yield
to just
increase likely profits I can't say for
certain but it would be a boon to this
industry to also treat these plants in
this way because if you can have better
yield you can feed more people you can
sell more so you can possibly increase
your
profits and these hydroponic systems
they can pretty much be installed in
many places right that's the have
Advantage yeah yeah they don't require a
lot of space I mean this cabinet behind
me
is I don't know
like yeah like three
three to four
feet high uh about the same wide and I
think two feet deep so that's with space
around it uh I have a vertical uh tower
garden it has a two foot footprint and I
think it is almost six feet tall and it
holds like 25 to 30
plants so like the space requirement for
hydroponic gardening is actually very
small and you can produce a good yield
like one that I have in my apartment I
use for salads I've got cherry tomatoes
growing on there I've got uh jalapenos
like I've got a variety of plants that I
just use to
supplement what I'm eating anyway oh
nice and so do you have any like
hypotheses for what type of music might
actually influence the growth of these L
say uh so from previous research it's
been noted that classical music is
supposed to increase uh plant
growth over uh no sound
control I don't I think that that will
likely hold but I'm also interested to
see I've got uh different groups so I've
got like nature sounds uh multiple
different forms of classical music I've
got uh different chants like VC Buddhist
and a mix I've got Christian music uh
Rock and
Jazz so honestly
I don't know which one will cause a
better
yield uh but if any of them cause a
better yield then I think that is a
success yeah and I well I think a
success success in terms of the science
but also success in terms of the proof
of principle of like the research hard
mechanism working rights as because for
you this is just like a passion project
at the moment it's not your full-time
job right yeah I'm doing this on top of
working a full-time job so this is in
the
evenings and so with like the research H
platform do you think that it's mainly
geared up for things like passion
projects like small projects that may be
easier to fund or do you think maybe
long term there is the chance that even
current researchers if they need extra
funding for a specific projects and just
didn't have the the grant or something
to cover it that that's also a
possibility I think it is a possibility
I can't say for certain what will happen
in the future but as
if more smaller projects are funded I
think that provides a proof of principle
that these that science can be
crowdfunded
and done
effectively if that can be scaled up to
larger projects I think that would also
be
beneficial yeah exactly and so I guess
the one thing that people would have to
know about is if uh is there a
requirement I mean I I feel like it's by
principle if you get funded through
research hub you should post all your
findings on the site right but there's
no I guess there's no necessary
necessary requirement for you to do so
or is a
um I think there's an Unwritten like
unspoken requirement like hey you should
be updating people if if you're working
in the decentralized science ecosystem
the point is to be transparent it's to
be effective as best you can like you
should be sharing ing these results with
people as they come out to help Garner
excitement and also provide verification
and validity to what you're doing
exactly um and so I mean are you
involved in any other DSi
projects uh not at the moment I've been
pretty heavily focused on just research
Hub I see and so I mean if the the
things progress as it seems to be would
you see maybe you yourself allocating
more time on the platform or for you do
you think it will always just sort of be
a sort of part-time um interest as
opposed to like a full-time career um if
as things progress I mean I have to see
depending on how my personal situation
kind of shakes out uh ideally I would
like to spend more time on the platform
and
helping as best I
can but nothing set in stone uh
everything kind of shakes out as it
will I see yeah well exactly um I so if
people wanted to also maybe try and get
projects funded what is the best way for
them to do that uh I think
just be active on Research Hub uh submit
thorough wellth thought out experimental
plans in the form of
pre-registrations
uh and just see where it goes from there
because if these are not if projects can
be
crowdfunded as they evidently
can it'll just be interesting to see
where it
goes exactly I mean why you surprised
when uh you got the funding for your
first project like how short it was I
was incredibly surprised I mean it
was a wild time like I mentioned before
it was two hours for funding
uh the whole
process in terms of uh like putting pen
to paper and actually writing down what
I wanted to do uh the whole process
maybe took about a month but there was
lots of support on Research Hub uh from
active users there like the community
there is fantastic very friendly very
helpful and obiously I mean obviously
when I think about research uh papers
there's obviously like articles
documenting experiments like you're
doing but there's also like R feww
articles where you sort of bring ideas
together do you think there's also maybe
similar chance for like funding to also
create sort of ref few documents that
could also be
valuable maybe uh I don't have a final
say on true what uh happens I think if
people wanted to submit plans like a a
detailed plan on how to structure a
review and what that would look
like I mean depending on
how people as a whole like on Research
Hub how valuable they would find that
they can tip their own uh research coin
to fund that I don't think that's
impossible to do
uh I think that the progression of those
things would be very exciting to see on
Research Hub like uh updates on how
documents are going I think ultimately
providing or creating micro Publications
in a way uh which could lead up to full
Publications that would be super
interesting because you can uh apply a
doi to posts on Research Hub a and you
can get effective uh peer feedback
through the comments also through inline
commenting so you can highlight certain
sections of posts and give specific
comments on
that piece of highlighted text because I
know that uh in review processes through
typical journals they kind of give you
like okay well these are are General
comments if the reviewers are good
they'll highlight the lines in their
final thing but there's no interaction
with the
document yeah where you can do that on
Research up and I think makes the
commenting much
easier yeah I think it's incredible uh
obviously applying the technology side
of things but also the speed of which
things can happen um which is just
amazing and I think the key thing that
you've highlighted already is that
decentralized science is all about
community and it's Community Driven and
so I guess maybe so one of the
limitations with the platform is it
takes time for communities to build
right um and so um do you think that's
yeah the main limitation with how the
the site is
going I don't know to be completely
honest uh the community around research
Hub has been growing steadily uh over
the past month it has definitely
ballooned and there's more discourse
more people coming in so you're getting
more insights and thus with more people
being active on the platform you have a
greater probability of interacting with
someone that has a matching expertise to
what you're looking for or that you have
so when I was using RAR CH I remember
sort of writing puse on the papers and
that was probably my last interaction
before I think the system had changed
again um compared to just uploading and
maybe commenting a bit about the paper
you would actually give some detail
about how you thought the paper was
conducted and comment on the research
itself yeah so on Research Hub I
mean one of the key aspects of the
platform is being able to do peer review
on uh preprints that come out of Med
archive or bioarchive so
as a user of the platform if you are an
expert in that domain I think
that you you can write a peer review if
you have sufficient knowledge I mean
that's kind of an
esoteric determination but if you feel
confident that like hey I know about
this I can give some
feedback uh you can do that on p on uh
research Hub and there are bounties
where people can specifically get
research coin for doing
that uh but but yeah
like that I think also
would increase the pace of science uh if
as more people come on to the platform
the authors will
be effectively made aware that hey there
are peer reviews going on of your work
there are people talking about it and
they can take that feedback and improve
the papers ideally or just see what
people are saying about it before those
papers get published the focus on the uh
pre-print is partly due to the fact that
a lot of papers still are behind payor
so obviously people who don't have
access like I got Journal access um
can't necessarily access it I mean I
know there are certain ways but um most
people can't access it so is that why
there's like a push more towards these
pre-prints yeah definitely I mean people
have been doing this research with a lot
of times publicly funded money and these
journals will come
in not really
I don't see a lot of their value prop
other than uh aggregating the this
information they will get peer review
for free from people in the academic
Community they'll curate this
into an issue and then publish it and
then say Oh anybody that wants to learn
about this thing that you did with
publicly funded money you're going to
have to pay more for that that's
nonsense uh the focus on preprints is
the fact that preference are posted for
free I think under like a general
Creative Commons license yeah so anybody
can see them and because preprints don't
have peer review on them already which
is something yeah because preprints
don't have peer review on them already
that gives an Avenue
for giving the authors feedback
on what they've written because the idea
is like you could do a peer review of an
already published paper but it's also
already been published and gone through
peer
review there's definitely comments that
can be made on every paper there's
always science is great but science will
never truly be complete because there's
always more to learn there's always
things that you may not have
considered
whatever uh but the focus on preference
is that they are open access and they
are at a stage in their publication life
cycle where comments could be valuable
and again on Research Hub like you can
get research coin for doing those
Publications which then you can take
that research coin and go and fund
projects that you think are interesting
yeah no I mean that's the aspect that I
always like about it and I guess like
longterm um there's there is a demand I
think definitely at least in the younger
generations going forward in academic
research as well that we want to find
alternative ways to publish without the
pay wall and you know I've had
situations where researchers have
published on a site that has a pay wall
and then they can't actually read their
own paper which I mean they can because
they have like the PDF but I mean they
can't on the website read their own work
which is just ridiculous but I guess
yeah long term if you have situations
like yours where you can actually upload
your own personal data um your research
data onto research Hub then in the
future if that's where people are
publishing then there is no pable to
begin with right so um I guess yeah long
term that would be the idealistic
solution definitely and I it would be a
better long-term solution uh also people
getting fairly compensated for their
time because peer reviews can take
depending on the paper can take a long
time and in the traditional academics
institutions people do peer review for
free because you know it's kind of
something you do which I think is
nonsense
everybody
has a specialty everybody
has everybody's everybody's time is
valuable and to be rewarded for that
value I think is
crucial and I think research Hub helps
facilitate that as
well I mean out of Interest have you
seen any competing uh I mean maybe
competing sort the right word because
it's so for good cause but any sort of
uh similar
sites that are trying to do the same
thing I don't know of any sites that are
doing something similar I know
bioarchive on
itself has an area to peer review but I
don't think that's highly
utilized uh there's definitely not a way
to be compensated for generating those
peer
reviews
uh do you know of any no I mean that's
why I I mean I like I see things that
are somewhat similar but also not the
same so definitely I think yeah research
to me at least feels unique I think yeah
I mean I'm you know classic academic
doesn't want to get involved in DDE but
has yet to you know I would love to
share my research but for certain
reasons I'm under you know agreement
that I can't due to my academic
situation um so uh yeah I no I
personally don't know any others and so
um hopefully in the future we will see
I'm mean more pushover to these
alternative modes of publishing um I
know like yeah when we first met I think
what I spoke to you most about was how
I'm also a big fan of using video as a
mode of communication and I know that at
least on Research Hub there is the
ability to link like YouTube videos um
as I mean I don't think we could ever
say written papers are going to be
redundant because they're just useful
for reference and having figures and
references and everything built in but
yeah being able to condense things in a
more FAL manner as well could be really
useful yeah definitely I mean the
people's attention span is very short
papers are long they're dense they
require very specific expertise to fully
comprehend or to not necessarily
comprehend but to appreciate what's in
them and I think the communication of
that through graphics and
video wildly helps
with with just science in general um and
yeah final thing that just I'm just
curious to ask you anyway this doesn't
have to necessarily be in the recording
but um obviously there's been like so
much advanc like chat gbt and all the AI
tools I'm not sure how familiar you are
with it but like obviously to some
extent it's easy to very much generate L
of like bad data like using these tools
and I just has research H considered
that already are they trying to like
factor that into consideration that
someone could just log in and be like
hey guys I got this idea and it's all
artificially generated nonsense I guess
that's part of the P few right you meant
to be able to spot it yeah that that's
part of peer review is the human aspect
of discernment of hey is this project
just a load of gobble deg that doesn't
really do
anything is it purely AI generated
because at like yes AI generated work
can be very similar to human generated
work there's also telltale signs of when
something is AI
generated so for example on Research Hub
peer reviews that are AI generated are
not accepted they're not because you
didn't put in the work to
help critique the information that's
being shown like yeah
I think that a fusion of hey you can use
AI to help you generate uh meaningful
content is definitely something that can
be used but like there needs to be
personal touches uh especially around
like funding
information there's
nothing yet but
also like being able to verif ver ify
that someone there is someone behind the
research proposal is key because you
can't just
go I think as a community funding
projects without knowing who the person
is that's doing it is a
Folly U and should be carefully
considered well I think it's well yeah
maybe then because as you mentioned to
to do your first proposal you've been on
the site for over a year now right so I
mean youve built up a good reputation so
I guess that there is some sort of I
think there is a reputation scoring
system right and research help that if
you consistently are acting good then
you know now you've surpassed the
thresholds and I'll be able to submit
your own proposal and it's just yeah
about gig and that Community aspect to
it that hopefully will eliminate this
from happening yeah and I mean
reputation it's Mercurial and also
important I mean the typical scientific
economy is
reputation
which I think is also nonsense because
there's game ways to game
that uh I mean how safe uh so you can be
an author on I think there was a case of
someone doing like 200 like an obscene
amount of research papers in a year did
they really write them are they just
Consultants uh there is uh self-
referencing of papers that you've done
which increases uh your H index and or
is it h score oh I mean I should ha us I
mean this I mean I want to care about it
but I also don't want to care about
whatever my score is yeah exactly like
there are ways that you can game it
and that has become a problem in
Academia because you you have people
artificially inflating their scores
you're like yeah I'm definitely
reputable but if you take a critical
look at like how how could you have done
that uh that's definitely an issue I
know on Research Hub there is reputation
uh based on what you've done on the
platform but there's also works to port
in other academic uh work that you've
done
to help build up your reputation score
and reputation
is something that is always going to
have bugs because there's no
determinable
metric I mean
I have proof of identity I've been
posting videos I've been posting content
for years now so like I have proof that
I'm a real person uh and have the
knowledge that I
do uh but reputation is something that
is
it's important uh it's difficult to nail
down exactly and I mean there's all for
trying to evaluate reputation there's
always going to be an everchanging model
that tries to best reflect what that is
because also how do you pull in
everything that you've done all the
Twitter posts all the blog posts all the
conferences you've gone to all the
people you've spoken to all the
presentations you've given the papers
you've written the videos you've posted
like already that's
close to 10 different factors also how
impactful is your research like
how credible is what youve
said hard to measure uh and so something
that I think is a crucial question to uh
Academia But ultimately as a value prop
for research Hub where Academia a lot of
the currency's reputation
because I think people in Academia
know they're paid
poorly yeah overworked uh
underfunded research Hub
brings monetary value
or I should say don't quote me on this
this is a personal thought uh but I
think that research Hub helps bring
monetary value to Scientific discussions
where there wasn't before so people can
actually get
appropriately compensated for their time
and expertise because on Research Hub
you can earn research coin through uh
comments
through having your content
upvoted having people tip you that they
when they think your work is good so it
helps kind of level the playing field
for
people uh in getting financially
compensated for their expertise because
yes reputation is important in Academia
but also like if you go to the grocery
store and you say hey this is my
reputation can I have some
food they're gonna say yeah cool um we
only accept currency like fiat currency
for the physical Goods that we have yeah
I like that um well first I'm glad you
are a ro person but so I completely
agree with the reputation aspect and I
think it's important having platforms
like this because it enables people I
mean I feel privileged obviously I come
from a good University so I come with
that expected good reputation but there
are many people who are doing good
research who just by their situation
don't have that as for granted and so
this gives them another way to achieve
it but also I maybe just think that
there something I feel like personally
I'm going to have to navigate throughout
my career where part of me is like you
know I want to go the academic Roots
have my lab Etc where at the moment the
whole system is still built around
publishing and academic journals whereas
there's also my own passion projects and
ideas I want to test maybe outside of
that space and how I balance the two
together or maybe I can find ways BR the
Gap I think it's definitely going to be
challenging but I'm willing to sort of
work work in testing see how it goes and
be an advocate for these s of platforms
that are also trying to achieve that
yeah I think decentralized science
definitely helps bridge that Gap because
personally I finished my masters and I'm
like yeah Academia is great it's not for
me I don't see
a
viable future
of being here I could I mean people do
do it uh personally I saw academic
lifestyle I saw professors and pis
struggling to get grants being
constantly stressed out people just on a
publish or perish mindset and really I
think something that's ingrained in
Academia unfortunately is a scarcity
mindset which really doesn't benefit
people
so I saw that and I'm like don't like
that not uh not for me so I went into
biotech uh and
that's what brought me to the States was
to do that but that also gave me more
time to even conceive of
and pursue this passion project so there
are ways that people can do science that
doesn't have to be in academic
institutions because science is not in
my in my opinion science is not
something that should be solely done in
Ivory Towers it's something that
people should have access to and I mean
there is a lot of science that does get
done that doesn't get recorded that
people don't know about there's lots of
uh folk wisdom there's lots of just
knowledge out
there that is science scientific but not
in what I think people would
traditionally
consider a scientific
format so trying to bridge that and also
help allow people to bridge that is a
huge task but also would be a huge
success yeah exactly I mean I'm
completely for it and can only encourage
my viewers to also if they're interested
as well to join the platform because I
think it really does take a community to
make these differences and if everyone's
doing it then we can by mass action make
uh better changes for the future yeah
and I mean that's I think also one of
the
responsibilities that people have who
are scientifically who are trained in
any aspect not just science uh is a
responsibility
to improve what was there before yeah
see things that see things that aren't
working and try and provide fixes for
them
to help the most amount of people yeah
they well said well I think um I I can
only wish you the best of luck of your
research project and I think I'm now
going to have to spend more time and
research Hub to to track the the plant
growth so it's actually it's a really
interesting uh projects but also I just
love the briefer principle that simple
projects that maybe aren't too expensive
really can just be funded through some
like this this approach which I think
could really help many people who have
interesting ideas who just need a bit of
funding to do it
yeah I mean I feel like when people
think about science they think about
large hundreds of thousands to millions
of dollars worth of funding yes that
does fund big labs and universities
universities also take an overhead cut
which I don't think people necessarily
know about that could be anywhere from
10% what's the highest you've heard I
I've heard I think the highest of like
40 to 50 W but I don't know I hope it's
not that high but
I've I've heard of that high I've
definitely seen 30% of research grants
going to overhead at
universities
uh but the fact the fact remains that if
you can feasibly come up with uh
inexpensive experiments that can also
push the pace of science forward and not
having to provide these large
Publications which have gotten
progressively longer and more
elaborate as the years have gone on
would also speed up the pace of science
yeah no I completely agree I'm also a
big fan of simple very nicely packaged
little papers I can digest so yeah I
really think um it's a really good
approach and I can anyway yeah wish you
the best of luck and yeah hope to hear
your
progress yeah I I'm hopeful I I'm
excited uh my research project I mean
with 16 plant treatments over the course
of basic basically a month each I've got
a year and a half timeline to round out
to an E easy
number uh so updates will continue to
come uh as they progress
and it'll just be neat I think uh one
thing as well to mention about science
as a whole uh because you and I both
have a background in science
communication you with this Shiki
science show me with my YouTube channel
which is investigate explore discover
I'll give a Shameless plug for anybody
that wants to check it
out uh science doing the science is
great unfortunately science does not end
with you just throwing it out into the
world you need to communicate your
science and help guide people
to why it's important and why they
should care about it and I think that's
something that a lot a lot of
researchers and
scientists don't know don't appreciate
aren't
told because it's a whole other aspect
to your research that I just think is so
critical because you can do the best
work in the world and do something
extremely interesting but if you're not
telling people about it if people don't
understand what you're doing or why
you're doing it I mean it just becomes
more words on a page somewhere exactly
no that's so well said and also I mean
as I mentioned earlier these smaller
projects like for you this is a passion
project and that passion is like the
most important thing when having out of
science because it doesn't just help
with you doing the science in the first
place but also the communication purely
for the fact that you're excited about
it um so yeah no definitely I completely
agree yeah well I will definitely put
the link to your research Hub Down Below
in the description and obviously I'll
link also to your project so my viewers
can track your progress too So yeah
thank you again for coming on to the
show thank you so much Elanor I really
appreciate you having me on uh it's been
fantastic to talk and I look forward to
hearing more of your interviews and your
science communication thank
you